the economy is in bad shape and it's
gonna stay a bad shape for a while it
kind of feeds on itself there are fewer
jobs are there fewer people will
spending money there for every reach
protracting and and then businesses have
smaller profit so they let people go and
it's it goes on and on so finally
somebody like Roosevelt comes along
because I hear but fear itself and then
fortunately with the world war two came
along and I've read basic recoveries of
the business well I don't think I want a
world war to rejuvenate our economy so
we're gonna have to learn to do it
ourselves now fortunately we're in a
what in a very global world and you know
it already takes one engine to get the
thing going again this time the engine
will probably the Far East China and
India but you know we also have to learn
how to place ourselves we have to say no
that's not the right thing to do I'm not
going to do it and that's how the
majority of businessmen are the big
majority businessman say that we're
still going to have the sort of problems
we have recurring